on the road to 2020 this morning the
crowded Democratic field is getting a
new candidate billionaire Tom Steyer now
it's this bid in a campaign video we
have a society that's very unequal and
it's really important for people to
understand that this society is
connected and steyr will be here in
studio 57 on Thursday for his first TV
interview since announcing his run ed
O'Keefe is tracking the race from
Washington and you talked to steyr in
February what did he tell you back then
well Tony at the time he said he
wouldn't run for president saying he
wanted to focus instead on increasing
public support for impeaching President
Trump but now Stiers campaign says he'll
focus initially on environmental policy
and ways to revamp the nation's
political system the 62 year old
billionaire former hedge fund manager
from California is a major Democratic
Party donor and environmental activist
his decision to jump in comes as another
Californian congressman Eric's wawel
announced he's dropping out of the
presidential race the first candidate to
do so since the debates at Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren announced some
big second-quarter fundraising totals
but how does she stack up against the
rest of the field yeah pretty well she
says she raised a little more than 19
million dollars in the last three months
that's more money raised in the past
quarter then every candidate except
former Vice President Joe Biden and
South Bend Indiana mayor Pete Budaj
but as she pointed out last night in New
Hampshire Warren's raising her money a
little differently I don't go to
closed-door fundraisers I don't hang out
with millionaires and corporate CEOs I
am building a grassroots movement and I
think as Democrats we should ask that of
every single one of them one other note
from the road to 2020 next year
Democrats in Iowa and Nevada will have
the option to cast votes using one of
these so-called tell Akaka Singh is
designed to make it easier for older or
disabled people or people stuck at work
to participate in caucuses that are held
at set times Tony
very interesting ad I think there might
be a piece in our future about that
phone voting day 2019 things change
thank you very much ed it's good to see
you had